in the last 24 hours and I believe I
know why I received seven or eight
emails asking me to debate charlie Kirk
okay if you don't know who Charlie Kirk
is I admire you and I envy you
Charlie Kirk is a right-wing bomb
thrower associated with the right-wing
group Turning Point USA the whole
premise of turning-point USA as I
understand it is that the left has taken
over our colleges the left has taken
over our universities and so what T P
USA or toilet paper USA is some no it
does is they go to colleges and
university and they say the universities
and they spout their bogus talking
points and they'll argue with people in
the crowd and you know sort of Ben
Shapiro like but not as rhetorically
skilled as ben shapiro
candice owens is another person
associated with the group if her name
doesn't ring a bell
i double envy you not even being
involved in these toxic cesspools
congratulations so here's one example
email that i received um yesterday in
fact dear david charlie kirk needs to be
brought down every year someone from the
progressive media challenges him in
every year i know it's not going to go
well hassan [ __ ] looked like a
rebellious teenage Punk saying f you to
his conservative father Sam cedar evaded
questions and looked easily fumbled and
ill-prepared and now kyle kolinsky as
much as i love Kyle and think he does
great work I knew as soon as I saw the
announcement this was going to be bad
for reasons you yourself I'm sure
surmise so I won't go into them and sure
enough while goofy and funny and
throwing a few good punches I do not
think Kyle did well in his debate in
this debate he was visibly nervous kept
pacing around his podium evading
questions and letting Kirk ramble on his
sales pitch with no interruptions it's
like none of these people did their
homework to find out what Charlie's
talking points would be and just thought
Charlie Kirk that [ __ ] that liar yeah I
can take them on I know my stuff that's
why I know you would be different I know
it would take a lot of work but you
understand what it's going to take to
take down Charlie Kirk and I think
you're the only one with the disposition
to be able to do it you know his debate
tactics throw out a ton of
misleading facts and half-truths in a
quick amount of time knowing a few of
them are bound to stick he's got at
least a dozen shotgun shells of
information ready to go at a moment's
notice he is not to be underestimated he
is really smart and has an obvious good
memory and you're the only progressive I
can think of that can match him so I'm
begging you David for the sake of the
progressive movement that I see getting
damaged every year by this a-hole take
this effort down you're our only hope
says John so let's go through this in
pieces Charlie Kirk has debated at
politican Hasan [ __ ] last year Sam
cedar last year I believe
and Kyle kolinsky this year just a few
days ago I've not seen any of these
debates other than five minutes of
Hassan versus Charlie in Los Angeles
during last year's politic on I saw the
part where gent ugar Hassan's uncle was
yelling at Charlie from the audience and
otherwise it was just Charlie and Hasan
yelling at each other I have no idea how
the debate went with Kyle over the
weekend but what I'm hearing is that
people are saying Sam Hassan and Kyle
didn't debate well and didn't look good
and David you would do better I don't
know that I would do any better I don't
really have any reason to think that I
would do any better than Sam Hassan or
Kyle in the debate format I'm flattered
that John and a few other people who
emailed me think so I actually think
that the problem is the debate format
the politican debate format is either no
moderator or you know like a showpiece
moderator who doesn't really moderate
with and this is important a crowd that
reacts to the basest lowest common
denominator talking points and starts to
interfere in the debate so I believe the
problem is the debate because when one
side cares about facts Hassan and Sam
and Kyle
generally speaking care about facts at
least as they see them right and the
other side cares about gotchas and
optics and kill shot moments and
repeating the same tired talking points
that are meaningless but they are
effective in front of a live audience
you were at a fundamental disadvantage
and so I don't know that I would do any
better in fact I may do worse because I
am more suited to a different type of
debate so to really debate these people
you need to be
able to go in depth without interruption
from the audience and without the next
talking point dear ailing everything you
need a formal controlled format that
bores a lot of audiences sadly it's not
going to create an event that will get
politican to shell out the cheques of
you know 10,000 15,000 25,000 dollars
per invited speaker or debater as they
do now I don't know if people know but
you know we get paid to go to politic on
so would i debate charlie Kirk I mean I
guess maybe would I do better than Kyle
salmon Hasan if the format is the same I
don't know that I do any better but my
focus and you know I've said I have a
story to tell about me not being at
politican this year and a big piece of
it was I had this emergency appendectomy
but there is more to the story I'm
really trying to focus on the important
stuff and productive conversation I want
to be talking to people who have read
philosophy and political theory not
people who repeat the talking points
that Candice Owens feeds them right I
think if I'm making myself clear I think
that's the best way to it sort of
elucidate it let me know what you think
why engage in debates with bad faith
participants when the format will not
allow you to actually expose them for
the intellectual frauds that they are
let me know what you think